Imagine this: you’re a researcher, with
an interest in and an aptitude for marine
biology.
Over the years, your work has taken you far
and wide, to the furthest corners of the Earth’s
oceans.
You’ve observed countless species of sea
life, from fish and crustaceans, to whales
and sharks.
Predators and prey alike.
During one of your travels, you find yourself
off the coast of South Africa, monitoring
the local population of sea creatures.
Looking out across the water, you see a large,
dark shape moving below the surface.
There is a shadow streaking its way towards
your vessel, dark as night, speeding like
a torpedo.
You rush across the deck, leaning out over
the port side as the shape swims beneath your
boat.
You’re certain you know what it was.
After all your years of studying the world
beneath the waves, you know a whale shark
when you see one.
The largest known species of fish still in
existence, the whale shark is a filter-feeder,
consisting on a diet of plankton and other
tiny aquatic organisms.
A whale shark poses absolutely no threat to
humans.
Or rather, any whale shark other than this
one wouldn’t pose a threat, but how could
you know that?
Scanning the water, you strain your eyes,
trying to spot what you assumed was an ordinary
whale shark swimming below.
But there is nothing, no sign of it anywhere.
Sighing, you think you might’ve missed your
chance to see one in the wild.
Perhaps it changed direction, instead of swimming
under the boat, you tell yourself.
The ship turns and starts making its way back
towards the small harbor, leaving you blissfully
unaware that there’s an extra passenger
on board.
As you disembark, you notice something on
the side of the boat.
Emblazoned on the hull is a motif of a familiar
shape: a whale shark, depicted entirely in
painted dots.
You stare at it for a moment, intrigued by
the pattern.
It reminds you of a piece you once saw, an
Aboriginal Australian style of dot-art.
You’re a little taken aback by the coincidence,
having briefly spotted a whale shark while
out at sea earlier, blissfully unaware that
this painting marks your first encounter with
SCP-1449, known more colloquially as the “Dream
Time Whale Shark.”
In fact, you’re so amused by seeing the
whale shark earlier, only to find one painted
here on this boat, that it distracts you.
You don’t realize that the whale shark painting
hadn’t been on the side of the boat when
you’d shipped out.
Instead, you pay the crew and thank the captain
for letting you hire the vessel for your research,
and then head off.
By the time you make it back to the nearby
town, and settle down in after a long day
on the water, the dotted painting of the whale
shark has already slipped from your mind.
But as you begin drifting off and everything
goes dark, you’re about to find out that
your encounter with the Dream Time Whale Shark
is only just beginning.
You’ve never been a heavy sleeper, and rarely
remember your dreams.
Any that you might have seem to pass out of
your head the moment you wake up, or are too
faint for you to acknowledge while you’re
sleeping.
But tonight is different.
Tonight, you’re dreaming vividly.
In this dream, water surrounds you, like it
has your whole career.
But this time, you’re underneath the surface,
adrift in an empty ocean, nothing around you
but endless, blank sea.
You feel something in your hand, something
smooth and moving gently like organic matter;
something alive.
You find yourself gripping the tail of a whale
shark and somehow, as is often the way with
dreams, you know that this is the same whale
shark from earlier that day.
The one that swam up to your boat, and ended
up sticking to the side of it as a dot art
painting.
SCP-1449 has this latent ability, while it
normally appears as a flat, two-dimensional
piece of Aboriginal Australian dot art, the
Dream Time Whale Shark can shift whenever
it is underwater.
It still appears as a collection of painted
dots in the unmistakable shape of a whale
shark, but in an aquatic environment it becomes
three-dimensional.
And that’s what you’d seen swimming towards
the boat, not just a whale shark, but SCP-1449.
Within your dream, you release the Dream Time
Whale Shark’s tail and begin to float upwards.
Breaking the surface of the water, you breathe
lungfuls of fresh air.
The first thing you see is land, and it’s
close by, close enough for you to swim to
the shore.
Paddling through the water, you reach an island,
one in a chain of small land masses, tiny
continents in a shallow, unfamiliar ocean.
You look back to the water, but can find no
sign of SCP-1449.
The Dream Time Whale Shark has brought you
here, and left you on this island, but you
can only speculate as to why.
There must be a reason, you insist to yourself.
The dreamscape around you, it would seem,
is either the creation of SCP-1449 or at the
very least a side-effect of falling asleep
close by to where you saw the Dream Time Whale
Shark in its painted form.
Whatever this place is, there must be some
way to uncover an answer.
It stands to reason, you think, that if you
can understand what’s going on, then perhaps
therein lies the key to escaping this dream,
and waking up back in reality.
The small island you find yourself on, and
the others nearby, are inhabited by strange
life forms.
As you walk across the shore, sand clinging
to your wet feet, you approach what you thought,
at a distance, to be a group of other people.
Instead, you see a group of peculiar beings.
They are not-quite human, but they’re definitely
close.
The closer you walk, you notice these strange
humanoid shapes huddle tighter together, their
backs to you.
When you try to call out to them, asking where
you are or how you might return to reality,
they bustle away.
The wind carries the sound of their chatter
towards you, and you’re certain you hear
them call you “another one, just another
traveler from afar.”
What you don’t realize, lost in this dream
environment, is that there are others like
it.
Pocket worlds like this one, similar but different,
currently being experienced by any others
asleep near SCP-1449.
As you ponder what to do on the beach, the
captain of the boat you hired is on a different
version of the same island, watching a herd
of multiple two-thousand kilo platypi being
shepherded by six, tattooed, three-meter tall
humanoid figures.
Meanwhile, his first mate is in another version
of this d
ream world, learning how to hunt under the
tutelage of a man called Grey the Rabbit Hunter.
Each version of SCP-1449’s dreamscape have
separate continuities to each other.
They are differing copies of the same chain
of islands, with the same inhabitants, but
each visited by a different “traveler from
afar” in their sleep.
Much like a lucid dream, visitors to the Dream
Time Whale Shark’s worlds can interact with
them, shaping and altering events in the continuity
they find themselves in.
Deciding to leave the beach, you elect to
make your way towards higher ground, to try
to get a wider scope of your surroundings.
Fortunately, there is a towering, mountainous
shape nearby, standing like dark, serrated
teeth against the clear horizon.
You begin your dangerous trek, ascending your
way up these dead, jagged hills.
You’re still unclear on how you got here,
or how to escape, but you will yourself to
keep climbing, knowing that there must be
some way to wake up from this bizarre dream.
Finally, reaching level ground, you take a
moment to catch your breath, collecting your
thoughts before advancing any further.
You turn, gazing out over the landscape spreading
out below and all around you.
The island is small enough you can see the
shore where you arrived, and the ocean flanking
this land mass on all sides.
In this short moment, you appreciate the beauty
of this bizarre dream world for the first
time.
The trees sway in the gentle breeze, moving
like the calm rolling of waves in the water
beyond, both glistening with the warm light
of the sun.
While it is still true that you have no idea
how or why SCP-1449 brought you here, or how
to leave, you think to yourself that at least
this dream environment isn’t a hostile one.
Not that you’d want to be stranded there
forever, but there are certainly far more
unforgiving places one can dream about.
A grim thought suddenly dawns on you.
How long have you been here?
Does time pass differently in this world to
the one you’re still asleep in?
A sound shakes your thoughts back to your
current here and now.
It was a voice, you’re sure of it, a voice
calling out but not to you.
Traversing the Dead Jagged Hills, you see
a figure, a person from the real world like
you, not one of the local humanoids.
They don’t see you; they’re calling out
to someone in a ramshackle hut cobbled together
from pieces of wood and other scraps.
On the arm of the figure’s dark, military-like,
uniform is a symbol, and you can just make
out three distinct letters: SCP.
A wooden plank that functioned as the door
creaked open, revealing a second figure.
The man looks disheveled, his worn clothing
patched with scraps of leather and shark skin,
making him look as cobbled-together as his
makeshift hut, like he was an extension of
the small structure.
You watch as the man talks to the agent, overhearing
his words.
“Don’t say anything.
If you say anything, I lose my mind.
You say anything and something horrible happens,”
the strange man warns, talking too quickly
for the Foundation agent to reply.
“You’re a dreamer.
Like me.
My name is Nikolai, I am the shipseer of Dhûnhome,
and of the brotherhood of Selachiosk Pungix
Combin.”
The man, Nikolai, he’d called himself, seems
distressed, tripping over his words, disagreeing
with himself until he starts trailing off
into swearing obscenities.
“I am not Nikolai,” he shouts.
“I’m ag…agent…agent…John?” before
stumbling and cursing again.
“I’m sorry…I can’t…can’t keep
the memories straight.
Being this lucid for this long hurts.
The dreaming fills in all the gaps.
Things have always been, even as they are
brought into being.
I’ve been on this cliff since the beginning
of time, just like how this place has always
been here.
The dream was torn away by the deaths of gods
before time began but I watched it happen
five years ago and…are you following?
I can barely tell the dream and reality apart
anymore.
My world has always been the way it is and
we made it like that.
We hurt the dreaming.
The shark, that’s how we see it.
We hurt it.
Killed it in our world and the dreamtime poured
out like its spilled blood and…
We made this big scar here, and…and…things
are wrong.
Fish walk and ghosts haunt the stones and
women give birth to plastic children and the
leech fields stretch out forever in the seas
of human blood and the Center eats cocaine
and caviar out of panda-skull bowls on the
crushed backs of opal mares in acres of broken
glass and it has always been like this.
Don’t…don’t do it.
Don’t do it again.”
You’re already racing back down the Dead
Jagged Hills, the sight of the deranged Nikolai
burned into your mind.
A man reduced to a babbling lunatic, castaway
and left alone in this strange dreamscape
that SCP-1449 brought you to.
But Nikolai is more than that, more than just
someone driven mad by his isolation.
He is a grim prophecy of what will become
of you, unless you can find a way to leave
the Dream Time Whale Shark’s world.
Already back at the beach, you drop down,
kneeling in the wet sand as the tide washes
over your knees.
The how, or why, of SCP-1449 bringing you
into this dream isn’t important, all that
matters to you is avoiding ending up like
Nikolai.
Whatever it takes, you know one thing above
all else: you need to wake up.
But whether you actually ever will is another
question entirely.
Now check out “SCP-343 - God” and “SCP-5000
- Why?
The Full Story Compilation” for more mind-bending
tales from the SCP Foundation!